this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app it's
great I don't know if you've seen it but
the cash app has this new thing it's
cool it's they've they've introduced the
cash card and it's a new black debit
card that you can design yourself via
the app the cash card allows you to use
the cash that you keep in the app
anywhere you want and you go anywhere so
that's good
now you have the cash app which is the
best way to people but back plus the
all-new cash card and I'll mention I'll
talk more about it later on in the show
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now what's up babies when I
start the show now that there's video
involved so that comes out by Thursday's
it's a little tricky because when we
first did the show an audio we would
just do it and then we would lay all the
music and later like the the beginning
of the song like the tame Thing Thing
Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing
Thing Thing you know the theme song and
and now that there's video I kind of got
a like wait while it plays and my
producer plays a stopwatch and it lasts
14 seconds and when I weighed it out and
he didn't do it this time one fire now
that's how we're starting the show with
one fire so I who knows how it will end
up going but one fire him he goes like
this whoopsie and he and they start
sitting is like just give it ten seconds
one fire um so uh like rounding it out
should be precise it's not precise it's
not precise I dude I guess I should
start
show by saying like you know it's always
weird like in comedy when some [ __ ]
tragic [ __ ] happens and then you have to
do like either a show or like I mean we
did it undateable once when everything
was happening in Paris and then we
actually didn't do undateable because it
was a live show and it was literally
going on a while we were going to record
the show so we didn't do it
and it felt like the right thing to do
and the Las Vegas thing happened last
night and you know but there's a podcast
and it's not even really that important
but the podcast and so I just I am
feeling [ __ ] weird man when that when
that kind of stuff happens I just you
know rightfully so it just [ __ ] me up
and so but you know so I just wanted to
say that my heart goes out to the people
in Las Vegas and that were affected and
the [ __ ] affects way more than just the
people that were you know injured so
it's just [ __ ] but that being said I'm
doing I'm gonna do the podcast and
hopefully it takes some people's minds
off it I guess even though there's stuff
that we have to think about regarding
that but I'm sitting here with my dogs
my - my - your keys and that's what's up
I am in I am going to be going to North
Carolina this weekend and I can't wait
to go I actually like going to Charlotte
every time I go dude when I'm on stage
in in North Carolina I play Charlotte a
lot and I play Rock Raleigh sometimes
but Charlotte a lot I've been going
there for years and every time I go I
want to say Charleston and I said it on
stage once they shouldn't have an okay
if you have a North Carolina and you
have Charlotte in North Carolina and
then you have a South Carolina first of
all
don't have to Carolina's just have
[ __ ] Carolina and then you know
swim swim town or whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call swim swim box I don't know
have a [ __ ] different have Virginia
don't have West Virginia was naturally
West Virginia is a then Virginia's [ __ ]
if you have [ __ ] Virginia and then
the one to the left of it is like well
we'll just be West Virginia how are you
gonna have [ __ ] non [ __ ] made dudes
there you're from the West version of us
we coined the term Virginia and now
you're just gonna be [ __ ] West
Virginia get your own identity get Yan
identity and so if you are North
Carolina and South Carolina okay here's
the thing too if you're gonna have North
Carolina and South Carolina also have
West Carolina and East Carolina because
then it's like you just didn't finish it
but there's North Carolina and South
Carolina there should just be Carolina
and whatever the [ __ ] else you want to
call it can't think of anything but for
some reason keep thinking of the words
swim which is very stupid but there's
Charlotte in North Carolina and then
there's Charleston in South Carolina a
sick confusing it's confusing so have it
be not North Carolina or South Carolina
and then also change it from Charlotte
and Charleston sounds too much alike to
me or just at least change the
difference [ __ ] I don't know
so whatever but I you know I don't know
I have you know what I realized too
so I'm in my room where I do my podcast
in ' and I have like odd [ __ ] in this
room because it's my [ __ ] podcast
room and like I'm staring at a [ __ ]
globe that I have which is over there in
the corner and I literally have no idea
how I got that globe but how about the
fact that there are still Globes you
know like that there are still Globes
and then also you can google anything
any map you ever want hey it's not the
1200s don't need a globe don't need a
globe if you have a venture to say and I
don't even know why I have one but if
you purchased a globe and you have a
globe even if it's just in your office
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude you're
a [ __ ] you're a grade-a
pompous [ __ ] you know that likes to spin
it around and look at the world you
think you're you basically think you're
God probably you basically think oh I
could spin this [ __ ] mini world
around and just look at wherever I look
at all the places that we've been we are
human gods that's what you think when
you have a globe and also if you have
the globe with the [ __ ] ring around
it and like the stand you're a huge
piece of [ __ ] like the big ring around
it will show it in the video podcast but
that [ __ ] one right there like it's
in place dude just have a [ __ ] the
the half ring around it you know I'm
talking about don't have that full
[ __ ] goddamn thing I don't know what
that was called but stupid and so
pompous [ __ ] but yeah so anyway don't
get Globes that's my [ __ ] PSA III do
I do the
rode a lot and like I do the road a lot
and no matter when I go on the road I'll
talk to you about obviously
succinylcholine and for the Forensic
Files [ __ ] hmm and then there's those
knockoff ones like snapped which I don't
really like that much because it just
feels like it's like it doesn't like
draw you in Forensic Files like
surrender Forensic Files is the one that
makes you it's like it's like the chick
that's like maybe I don't want to [ __ ]
yet but snapped is like the one that
makes that's like what's up what are we
doing later and you're like dude you
need to play it a little cooler you know
it's like so in-your-face and and the
graphics are just too much it's like
though it's like the [ __ ] [ __ ] girl
at the bar and the Forensic Files is
like the one that's like I just
something interesting about that girl
but I there's one I got to talk about
this one guy dude that I always see
infomercials on and and I and this is
not an ad dude okay the [ __ ] the my
pillow guy do you guys know the my
pillow guy first of all google this my
pillow guy he's got the most he nobody
could look like an uncle more than this
guy that's just how it is he literally
looks like the uncle like when when
[ __ ] Jesus Christ or whoever made
people was like hey this guy's brother
has a wife and kids this is the guy okay
look there's a by the way let me start
off by this saying I love this [ __ ]
guy okay I love this guy I love I love
what he represents I love his passion
for making pillows and I also love the
way he looks and I love his attitude and
I love how he talks to the camera okay I
know this is not ironic I [ __ ] I want
to meet this guy I like the guy okay if
you google this guy all that comes up is
the number-one 100%
most [ __ ] pictures of all time because
he's literally hugging a pillow okay
like it's his leg your key like it's his
chihuahua he's hugging a pillow he's
holding the pillow like it's a cell
phone that's what he's holding it
scroll up look at this [ __ ] guy
like it like it's a receiver he's
holding it like he's downloading
information into his brain about the
pillow this guy never doesn't hold the
pillow like this in every picture you
google he's holding the [ __ ] pillow
like this
[ __ ] ass and he's got and he looks like
an uncle okay now this guy literally
says I don't know what his name is but
he literally said it's called the my
pillow my pillow okay
he literally he's like I've created
I've made my whole life creating the
world's most comfortable pillow and and
and so I got to see this guy now when
I'm on the road it's a number one
commercial that plays I swear to God I
flipped around TV and channels and [ __ ]
like that this guy's always in the same
button-down blue shirt [ __ ] comparing
pillows and holding his pillow like it's
a [ __ ] cell phone I've spent my life
creating the world's most comfortable
pillow he basically says this pillow
will cure HIV like he basic basically
talks about how amazing this pillow is
okay now four years ago I'm in and now I
see this all the time for years now okay
so four years ago I see this this this I
mean I'm in Jacksonville Florida which
is a cesspool okay which is cool and no
disrespect if you're from Jacksonville
Florida but you're from a cesspool and I
wonder why when you're in Jacksonville
it it it literally feels like you're
swirling around and I always wondered
why and it's cuz it's a toilet bowl okay
and the people from Jacksonville you
could be like no but I grew up here and
it's [ __ ] got a hit by it successful
any place that has mini lakes with
alligators around it leaf alright so now
I am playing the Jacksonville funnybone
four years ago now hated it you know why
because the comedy club was literally in
a Radisson in makeshift buy it had
[ __ ] speakers on stands by and they
the the [ __ ] green room was another
hotel room in the Radisson in and it was
uh and it was so so bad I mean I would
never get serviced the [ __ ] waitstaff
wouldn't come in and check on me or
whatever but um the comedies on yeah I
told my agent I'll never [ __ ] play
that place again but anyway good comics
you should go
so they set me up with this room and
they're like we got the room for you
it's already I got in there the carpet
was [ __ ] wet that is so wet the
carpet was like the maid staff [ __ ]
pissed on it over and over again like
that was where they went to pee and I
went down and I was like hey why is this
carpet [ __ ] wet and they were like oh
cuz we shampooed it because we knew you
were coming and I said when did you do
it and they said oh we did it like eight
hours ago
hey man it's gonna be [ __ ] wet dude
I'm talking about I was walking around
in socks and my socks were soaked okay
change it do it a few days before that
or don't even do it I don't give a [ __ ]
don't do it alright so I'm there and I I
and this my pillow commercial has been
playing for [ __ ] it's always on it's
always on everywhere so I go to sleep
and I wake up and I have a and like I
pinched a nerve in my neck like I [ __ ]
pinched a nerve in my neck I literally
can't move my body okay I'm [ __ ] I'm
staying in bed I can't breathe I'm
breathing and when I'm breathing I'm
like oh god I'm like it like feels like
my chest is caving in and [ __ ] like that
cuz I can't do too much because my whole
body is just giving out just because of
this one pinched nerve and I'm like
Tyler the doctor what I do I finally
start to work it out I get up and
Jacksonville since it [ __ ] sucks
donkey balls
I was bored as [ __ ] and even though I
was in pain I walked over to this
[ __ ] 7-eleven or some [ __ ] and I'm bi
and I'm buying like who knows what I'm
[ __ ] buying coffee probably and I and
as I'm paying for it I look over
and I see this [ __ ] jackass this
uncle on a [ __ ] thing with a pillow
on it and he's [ __ ] downloading the
information into his [ __ ] brain
holding this pillow it's that bitch-ass
picture of him holding his pillow
everybody's uncle just sitting there and
he's looking at me he's looking right at
me thinking my pillow and he's looking
at me and he's thinking I know you've
only because it's another thing too it's
like you can't find it in stores how
about how [ __ ] is that when they're
like you can't find it in stores and
then you go to Target and it says
[ __ ] and yeah they have it not only
do they have it it says as-seen-on-tv
hey [ __ ] yourself man pick one is it not
in the stores or is it as seen on tv
whatever but you can't say it's not in
the stores in the [ __ ] stores guess
what
everything's in the stores also
everything's in the stores even now and
it's [ __ ] 2017 when you don't even
need to go to a store you don't even
need to go to a store and they got the
nerve to [ __ ] tell you it's not in
stores and then you go to a [ __ ]
Target or a for a 7-eleven and it's like
as seen on TV you [ __ ] [ __ ] so I'm
there and it says as seen on TV my
pillow [ __ ] and this guy does [ __ ]
uncle looking at me and my neck is
killing me
now this guy these infomercials that
this guy has I mean I would watch them I
would watch them over and over and over
again because it was all that was on and
I love infomercials in a non ironic way
I like them they're [ __ ] they kill me
they let me laugh cuz these guys don't
usually don't give a [ __ ] about these
products they Hawk these guys can
usually these guys are guys that they
hire there's one guy out there that is
so [ __ ]
dude why do they always always look like
molesters man this guy's so [ __ ] he's
got beige hair and a beige face same
face color as hair color he I call it
the Karl Rove okay now this guy has and
he's into plumbing and he's and he's
just jacking these [ __ ] products
he sells one thing that's these
Christmas lights that you hold out that
you it's not that my pillow guy but this
is the one Christmas like he'll hold it
be out like you put a a projector out on
the street and then it shines on your
[ __ ] place and they're like you don't
need to spend
all these [ __ ] hundreds of dollars
getting guys to hang lights on when you
can just [ __ ] blast a bunch of like
lights from your yard
to your house and it looks like the
light it doesn't look like the lights
are being [ __ ] strung up on your
house it looks like your your house is
under an alien attack it's horrible and
then for Halloween they sell one where
you put it on the inside of the house
and it projects outside of the [ __ ]
on the on the curtains or on the on the
shades and it looks like somebody's
killing somebody in the shower and they
make it look so good on TV and then you
buy it and it's so janky its janky as
[ __ ] there's a movie called janky
promoters with Ice Cube and Mike Epps
you know janky promoters anyway um
Halloween laser projectors [ __ ] so and
then that same guy sells another [ __ ]
razor cutter thing that can cut through
anything and he didn't invent the guy he
didn't invent a [ __ ] he's just like the
guy that they get that's like they're
like hey will you sell this to me and
he's like sure I feel like this guy is
so passionate about the product but he
doesn't give a [ __ ] you know he doesn't
you know he shows up and he's like
what's the product and he's like well
here's what we'll do I'll talk about it
like this is there a money-back
guarantee how many [ __ ] installments
can you do
I got this [ __ ] give me my blue
button-down I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna
rape the [ __ ] out of people that have
basically no money and then he goes and
he's like this can cut through anything
look and he'll [ __ ] like it'll do
everything you like scrape it against
stone look I'm doing [ __ ] 20 years
worth of damage right now and it'll
still cut it'll still cut a flower and
you're like yeah well no [ __ ] but then
idiots will be like oh man it still
works huh yeah look what happens if I
[ __ ] all over it in black and white it
shows him [ __ ] on on the thing on
your old tool that you would use and
then a red X over it you're getting used
to do that and now you can with the
slicer [ __ ] all over it it still works
look you can cut your mom your mom comes
out oh my god and for some reason people
just it's like a [ __ ] black hole son
video or some weird [ __ ] and and so this
guy these guys you hire okay and I love
these guys because they're [ __ ] what
is their job dude they just show up and
sell [ __ ] that they don't
leaving how is that something chuck
norris with the total body the total gym
he didn't give a [ __ ] about that he
didn't give a [ __ ] about that he showed
up with Christie Brinkley was like what
is it it's so funny you watch the
original Total Gym video not the one
that they remade they remade it but the
original one you can see in Chuck
Norris's face you can see him thinking
what the [ __ ] is this workout thing I
mean just look at him working out in the
original he doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
this guy does a martial arts for years
and years and years he's got some core
strength and this [ __ ] dude is like
oh yeah it really works all you got to
do is [ __ ] grab a [ __ ] [ __ ]
handle and pull it seven times and you
look like Lee Haney Hey you grab a
handle pull it eight times and your
[ __ ] Chi green or whatever the hell
that guy's name is so uh so uh so and
it's always two months no risk and you
lazy [ __ ] buy it and never return [ __ ]
and they make [ __ ] a hundred and
forty nine dollars off of you also who's
getting tricked by the 99 oh it's a
hundred and forty nine ninety nine just
make it a $150 what are we [ __ ]
plants what [ __ ] CUDA gets mixed up
oh it's 999 well alright and then would
actually think if it was a hundred
dollars no that's too much dude get
captured if that's how you are get
captured you understand by a villain and
be in a [ __ ] basement and get fed
bread and water cuz SWAT should deserve
get captured so
those are these guys so those are these
guys right they are for hire you
basically say hey I got stamps I want to
sell I'll give you [ __ ] this much
money to hawk him and he shows up in his
blue button-down with his [ __ ] cherub
face and he does it and you buy the [ __ ]
you know why cuz it works that's why
alright now there's this my pillow guy
he [ __ ] broke the system for me
because this guy is passionate about
this pillow and he made this pillow
created it and loves this pillow and you
can tell he loves the pillow because of
the way he holds the pillow on the
[ __ ] photo that's ubiquitous you
can't see a photo of this guy without
holding a goddamn pillow he's not
Hawking any other thing he's not Hawking
stamps or a [ __ ] knife this guy made
a pillow and it's my life dream to make
the most comfortable pillow of all time
for some reason because obviously when I
was younger I was molested by a pillow
like who is so weird
but the guy is the [ __ ] and I mean that
cuz I always say if you're [ __ ] gonna
do something in your life
for your profession make it something
you're passionate about dude when I go
on stage I [ __ ] want to do well I go
up I [ __ ] it's my life I do it every
night I am a comedian I am a comedian
Popeye
it's the spinach because he's [ __ ]
Popeye dude not cuz he wants to be
Popeye it's who he is this guy is a
[ __ ] pillow maker bro
yay and I'm serious you don't hire him
for [ __ ] like this so this guy would
have infomercials on and [ __ ] and and
and and I know and I know I know that
this is a long story but I don't give a
[ __ ] you understand me this is important
this is an important thing in my life
okay so I would see this guys [ __ ]
enforce it and I don't know this guy
from dick I don't know this guy from
[ __ ] other guys that are bit like
Billy Mays and Hawking all this [ __ ]
that you can just buy I don't know I
don't I don't know so I'm in and the
infomercial that he had to was like just
[ __ ] people were like testimonials
like I'm like literally like standing in
like what do you have to say there's an
audience and one guy was like I I like
you know it was affecting my marriage
the way I snored and I couldn't sleep
and I had sleep apnea and like I had 48
like literally like crazy [ __ ] like the
doctor said I wouldn't live for another
[ __ ] five years I bought this pillow
and it literally changed my life this
guy's getting choked up talking about it
in front of people I I'm getting you
know um my wife
our um our marriage has never been
better all because of a [ __ ] pillow
now I being the comedian I'm but like a
[ __ ] this asses because we're paid and
[ __ ] like this so now I'm at the [ __ ]
Jacksonville cesspool I'm at the
7-eleven I turn around and I see this
[ __ ] uncle staring at me downloading
a pillow into his brain and I'm like
okay [ __ ]
okay I'm in Jacksonville I don't want to
[ __ ] be here [ __ ] it I got a neck
pain I got nothing to lose dude I got
nothing to lose it's the [ __ ] middle
of the movie where you're like where's
this even going right so I look over to
the [ __ ] foreign guy of course and I
say I want that too and he says okay
rings up a [ __ ] I don't even know
fifty dollar pill I have no idea I have
no idea how much it was so I [ __ ] get
the goddamn pillow I take my coffee I
walk
back because I didn't have a car and I'm
walking and it's all [ __ ] hilly and
[ __ ] for no reason for some reason
Jacksonville's flat but also hilly I
don't understand how it is it's flat
because flat some more depressing than
rolling beautiful hills but also you get
the added how come I can't [ __ ] walk
on this flat ground easily because
everything is humps by and you got to
watch out for alligators and crocodiles
too or whatever the [ __ ] so I'm walking
back to my hotel and I get through my
show with my pain and I'm like alright
[ __ ] alright uncle let's get
this [ __ ] going let's see what the
[ __ ] going on let's fall asleep on
your goddamn life-changing pillow so I
[ __ ] take it out of the thing you got
to leave it for 30 minutes you know
everything that you buy on an informer
so there's like extra rules for it which
is annoying as [ __ ] it's like leave it
free for 30 minutes or like dry it or
like leave it in the Sun for the vacuum
to work better so anyway I leave it out
and then I [ __ ] fall asleep on this
pillow and I can't even move I wake up
dude listen to me dude this isn't an ad
I'm Chris D'Elia the comedian that tells
you the [ __ ] truth dude I'm not gonna
steal my babies wrong dude this is a
cult and by the way somebody my friend
was like yeah I know it's funny that
your joke about your cult and let me let
me just [ __ ] dial it in Here I am I
am a comedian everything I say on this
podcast is a joke okay this cult sure
joke around unless you really want to do
it then show up and we'll go to a log
cabin and for real I'll be the [ __ ]
leader okay all right so it's not really
a joke I'm not gonna steer you [ __ ]
wrong dude I woke up and I didn't have
[ __ ] neck pain dude it was the it was
I woke up and I thought I was dreaming
I didn't understand he was like 25% of
the pain that I had and I [ __ ]
brought you know how you know how you
know me you know me if you've listened
to the episode [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
that I don't [ __ ] you know how much I
would hate somebody on hey you oh you're
bringing a [ __ ] carry-on on the plane
and and it's a pillow stay home staying
bed I brought that [ __ ] pillow back
with me dude I brought that pillow back
with me because as much as I can't stand
a khuda that does that it's free conch
okay I had it in my head
free conch I'll bring it and I did and I
[ __ ] been sleeping on that pillow for
five years not only that I went on
Amazon cuz you can buy it anywhere even
though they say you can only buy it on
the website I went on Amazon and bought
four more
I bought big ones I bought small ones my
pillows dude every time I see see those
see my [ __ ] infomercial no
matter who I'm with I said you got to
get that [ __ ] it'll change your
life dude it's unbelievable this guy and
that's and that's what leads me back to
this do what you [ __ ] love do what
you love man that's it you can and I
know it's hard to get a job out there
and if you're lucky to just get a job
but also have that and you don't need to
be everyone wants to be a [ __ ] singer
or an artist or a [ __ ] dude maybe you
love making [ __ ] pillows dude you
don't know there's so many things out
there you're like botany maybe like
[ __ ] botany dude learn about spider
plants and [ __ ] ferns to me suborn
[ __ ] but [ __ ] look don't be the
[ __ ] guy that doesn't like his job
dude I get it when you're young you got
to do it but [ __ ] you know nobody
works harder than the rock nobody works
harder than the rock that's why the rock
is the [ __ ] that's why the rock is the
number one [ __ ] action movie star and
biggest a man alive
cuz he's the [ __ ] he became himself
dude it's about becoming yourself that's
what it is it's about becoming yourself
and then you go to overboard sometimes
when like your Al Pacino in a movie and
he's just so out for Chino and [ __ ]
you're like oh yeah you went a little
overboard but that's what it is you you
got a [ __ ] become who you are I know
I know that was a long story but I don't
give a [ __ ] man you get that goddamn
pillow and I'm and I'm this guy probably
that was just thousands of dollars with
of promo [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] dude I
want to hang out with that guy find out
who that guy is tweet him and tell him I
want to kick it with him my pillow I'll
have a coffee with him and I'll [ __ ]
video it how about that my pillow I've
spent my life ever since I came out of
the womb I landed on a pillow it wasn't
comfortable my first word was pillow my
first word was comfy because I wanted to
be comfortable
most pillows might as well be burlap I
spent my life and my life savings he
says this I spent my savings into making
the most comfortable pillow of all time
I have a 60 day guarantee
and also a 10 year guarantee and it's
made in it and it's made in America to
pack premium my pillows save 30% and
then also if you scroll down even more
you can probably find something that
saves 50% I also have my pillow for four
dogs which is stupid but it doesn't
matter because people are kouddous and
they'll definitely buy these pillows for
their dogs the outside roll and go
travel pillows why do I have my
moustache is made of my pillow when I
kiss a girl it's the most comfortable
kiss she will ever have
it will change her life under my nose I
have scientifically engineered a pillow
why would anyone have a moustache why
would anybody have a moustache it looks
weird to only have a little bit of hair
that you groom on your
face because your face is your face
would anybody have a mustache you know
the second you [ __ ] cut any part of
your hair and your face to shape it to
me you can't I can't take you seriously
as another person who doesn't do that
anyway do what you love how about me
undies you want to look good in your
underwear and be comfortable
don't you perfect balance is hard to
find right you sacrifice style for
comfort of comfort for style but check
out my undies dot-com find the best pair
of underwear in the world now I got them
on right now it's it's all I wear me and
these are awesome meters are so great
it's like the most comfortable pair of
underwear that you own a hundred percent
they're made from sustainably sourced
naturally soft fabric that is three
times softer than cotton it's it's very
true and it's like it hits you over the
side of the head when you put on these
underwears you're like oh wow this is
very comfortable and then immediately
you're like I can't use any other thing
but these underwears it's like falling
in love and then remaining faithful
that's what I do with these underwears
100% satisfaction guarantee they
guarantee you will love your undies or
your money back
get your 20% off these free shipping and
their 100% satisfaction guarantee and
get the best and softest underwear you
will ever own go to me undies dot-com
slash Congrats
that's me on DS dot-com / congrats
limited time offer what are you waiting
for start wearing the best underwear of
your life it changed my life honestly
it's time to let me on these change
yours go to me on DS comm slash Congrats
right now tracker this is what you
is what's important to you wallet phone
keys wallet phone keys why does leaving
the house always turn into the most
annoying scavenger hunt ever right
eight years ago tracker changed
everything when they released their
first tracking device and now they've
done it again with their all new tracker
pixel tracker pixels the latest
Bluetooth it's the lightest Bluetooth
Trac tracking device on the market place
tracker pixel on whatever you tend to
lose your keys your wallets whatever
your cat small enough to fit anywhere
all right
and then they'll help you find it you
use your smartphone and a 90 decibel
alert will help you find it in seconds
has powerful LED lights so you can find
anything even in the dark you lose your
phone just press the button on your
tracker picks on the phone rings even if
it's on silent 30-day money-back
guarantee guarantee you got nothing to
lose go to the tracker comm / congrats
to get 20% off any order that's the
tracker th e TR ack are.com / congrats
for 20% off the tracker dot-com /
congrats square cache everyone is
switching to the cash app because it's
the best way to pay people back friends
family coworkers
probably the my pillow guy sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in
seconds here's how it works you download
the the square cash app link your debit
or debit card select an amount to send
and type in a friend's phone number or
email address to complete a payment
they'll get a notification they've just
received money that's it no gimmicks
Square cash is better than the other
guys
it's not a social network that's what I
like about them because I don't wanna
have my payments listed in the feed
that's not cool that's good ok so let's
talk about the new cash card that I
talked about earlier it's a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app it's the cash card allows
you to use the cash that you keep
anywhere and you want it cash the the
sorry the money that you keep in the
cash app it lets you use it anywhere you
want you'll get notifications for all
payments that made with the card
directly via the cash app the cash app
team is consistently building awesome
new features so what you're doing using
so what are you doing using you know not
them I'll fight you basically if
if you're not using them so get the cash
up today download the free cash app for
iOS or Android now so yeah
do you love that's what I'm trying to
say not trying to be inspirational
because I don't like to be inspirational
I was inspirational by mistake okay I
know everyone loves to be that's why we
got the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week that's how we did that because
of how inspirational people like to try
and be how about when people [ __ ]
write you how about when people write
you what do you call it how do you ask
you [ __ ] like when they're posted in
Instagram and they're like what do you
think should I write this as a captioner
this is a caption and you're like oh I
don't I don't give a [ __ ] I don't even
care what I write as a caption but what
do you think you think this filter of
that filter oh [ __ ] man that's that
means nothing in my life woody what do
you think looks better this one or that
one oh dude you know what to jump off a
train that's going oh [ __ ] oh man I lose
respect for you is this funny to write
this oh I don't give a [ __ ] you know why
you work at a bank
see ya it doesn't matter doesn't matter
your life snot that poor and sure it's
free conch but it's also
courage if I wanna you know say go [ __ ]
yourself I can say go [ __ ] yourself um
yeah I had a buddy that does that don't
like does that [ __ ] I don't hey I love
my dogs come here Sam come here Bubba
come here butters Sam come on jumpin up
come on come on come on you [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] come here jump up what's
up dude and I do this come here come
here
good boy people say that these dogs I
have to your keys people say that
they're they're gay that's stupid
bro what are you talking about they're
cute
what do you mean well I got to get a
bulldog to be a man [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] I don't like when people
do this [ __ ] that's so obvious you know
it's like oh [ __ ] okay because you're a
[ __ ] guy that goes to the gym you're
gonna get a [ __ ] let me guess a pit
bull oh and do you have a chain leash
[ __ ] out of here what do you Hercules
hey never have a chain okay what do you
Hercules dude what are you a [ __ ] but
this dog [ __ ] it not gay let's [ __ ]
love dude it's not gay to have [ __ ]
your keys I mean it could be gay
if you [ __ ] dress them up and [ __ ]
and you're gay it's annoying
a real doctor I get a real dog like what
dude like what a Rottweiler when was the
Rottweiler the cutest when it was a
[ __ ] puppy no [ __ ] my dogs stay in
this way you [ __ ] [ __ ] right
um so anyway I don't know man I can't
that [ __ ] my pillow story exhausted
me
it [ __ ] exhausted me
all I know is oh dude oh man by the way
remember when Matt texted us the [ __ ]
picture I'm talking to my producer and
your jeans were so [ __ ] big okay I
have I found a picture of me I found a
video of me that a fan came up after a
show and was like my sister knows you
he's like she has she posted this video
on Facebook and his picture of his a
video of me in a play doing a play I
think it was doing a grease or some dumb
[ __ ] and I was like 19 or 20 and dude I
my pants dude my [ __ ] pants I could
have fit a family in them dude they were
so baggy it was it was a it was a joke
it was awful I didn't remember having
those pants so baggy that was the style
baggy is [ __ ] pants like it was like MC
Hammer pants and it wasn't my outfit for
the play dude it was actual they were
and dude they were red bro they were red
and I don't dude think of I'm not
talking baggy I'm talking like like they
almost dragged with me you remember I
had those pants dude I think there were
Abercrombie and Fitch and I think they
unzipped and could turn them into shorts
and I never did that even back then I
knew that that was some dumb [ __ ] dude I
don't know if Abercrombie & Fitch made
created that [ __ ] but that's so dumb
that you'd sell them in a department
store in Glendale Hey Dude don't unpack
you have shorts or you have pants if you
have pants that unzip into shorts you
better be [ __ ] Bear Grylls
you better be Cameron Hayes you better
be [ __ ] Batman bro
pant
zip into shorts oh how about a guy you
know there's one guy out there that
thinks it's dope to just do one leg oh
what the [ __ ] is that one where you
could do three do it there's one where
you can zip them into shorts or shorter
shorts
I mean how I mean imagine getting ready
through there come in three sections
imagine getting ready we'll have this on
the video podcast imagine getting ready
and being like what length should I do
and then be like oh unzip this unzip it
here and then this and I just add this
or should I have this what dude just get
different pants [ __ ] what if there
were four sections what if someone made
five section pants we could just
constantly keep adding rings like rungs
oh man dude just I don't you know I bet
there's out there there's [ __ ] shirts
we can let look at that [ __ ] a hoe in
the middle no and then with the [ __ ]
over there on look at all with the
[ __ ] ripped in the butt yeah how hey
yeah but a woman can do what she wants
sure but you know if you have a [ __ ]
rip in your [ __ ]
in jeans see how I want to get rid of
dude I always always love to get speedos
I love speedos bro
I love speedos man I wear I wear speedos
I don't give a [ __ ] I tried I want the
mum I wanted to wear him at the beach
once and my mom told me I couldn't I was
like 30 my mom was like Christopher my
balls were peeking out the side a little
bit but that's the joy of a speedo man I
love speedos you know why okay you know
what dude and for all my French
listeners
you obviously know where I'm coming from
cuz wearing Speedos I mean you might as
well be holding a [ __ ] like easel or
whatever the [ __ ] and like painting
because or have a Flint French flag on
the okay you know what go ahead go ahead
you think I [ __ ] okay where
boardshorts fine wear shorter shorts
fine okay put on a speedo go in the pool
whose
laughing now joke's on you bro it's
serious business you feel like you're
being born that's how comfortable it is
put a speedo on let your nuts breathe
and be in the pool you're welcome
how's that how's that you're welcome put
a speedo on be around people have them
laugh at you jump in the pool you're
welcome you're welcome
speedos are the [ __ ] you don't know
because we're embarrassed
oh you're embarrass your dick might
[ __ ] poke out the side
so what be a man oopsy-daisy
whoopsie you caught my balls guess what
I'm being comfy as [ __ ] and it's free
conch and dude yeah I get it you know
it's all you know people think it's you
know embarrassing if a fat guy wears a
speedo [ __ ] that bro wear it but don't
be fat for health health reasons but
wear it you get to wear a speedo just
like a skinny guy [ __ ] go out
there and enjoy your life and be yeah I
get it I get it looks silly be more it
but it's not though it's not it's not
silly that's how underwear [ __ ] looks
you don't need to wear boxer briefs and
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] long ass board
shorts how about that how about that
when people wear long ass board shorts
and they're in a pool and they get at a
pool and 40% of the water comes out with
it hey dude you're wearing curtains dude
you're in water what's with all the
fabric put on a speedo get in the pool
you're welcome chicks wear them they
cover their titties too but chicks wear
them I bet they're I bet their [ __ ]
feel so good in the [ __ ] pool like
that
I want my dick to feel good too man be
fat where
I love how people are like yeah it's
healthy to be fat though it's like yeah
ok but some of the pictures are showing
it's not healthy to be that fat okay oh
you see these [ __ ] pictures out there
online oh props to her for living the
way she wants to a she's gonna die early
be fat don't be that fat don't be that
fat that's it don't be that fat or else
you'll die of diabetes don't be that fat
you lose your feet you're gonna [ __ ]
lose weight one way or another you're
they're gonna [ __ ] shut it off
working out and not eatin [ __ ]
doughnuts or you can get your feet cut
off doctor with the worst bedside manner
ever hey so you're gonna need to work
out or I'm gonna have to cut your feet
off take two of these call me in the
morning yeah oh man I [ __ ] by the way
talk about being fat I've worked out so
hard okay I crushed six ice cream
sandwiches last night you ever done that
[ __ ] you ever done anything like that
you have have you
okay okay actually that makes me feel
much [ __ ] better six bro okay so you
haven't then my producer [ __ ]
literally lied to me in this small room
you ever done anything like that he goes
yeah I said six he says no which is it
bro I [ __ ] ate six and I and you know
what dude I chose to be done
I could have eight nine [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's it I could never stop eating you
know how people are like oh how about
portions what huh portions huh how much
did you make that's mine what are you
talking about portions yo do you know
how many times I haven't eaten other
people's meals that weren't done to only
when I'm in a professional
setting if I'm with a girl if I'm with
my mom or brother gimme that - dude what
are you talking about portions how much
did you make
dude my uncle's this way - my dad's not
this way my dad elite a portion the [ __ ]
my brother will eat a portion of the
portion what are you trying to fit in a
swimsuit what is your mind doing give me
all the taste bro I'm full here but this
[ __ ] feels jolly up here still my tongue
is dancing through that flavor is
dancing around my mouth yeah I'm working
on a [ __ ] I'm working on filling up a
toilet bowl in my bottom section but
that food is having a [ __ ] Mardi Gras
party dude the pasta in my mouth is
yelling at the sauce telling it to show
its tits that's how much I want in my
[ __ ] mouth
it's throwing a 40th over-the-hill
birthday party in my mouth and I'm not
done inviting people can my friends come
yes are they tasty
give me that two portions come on dude I
mean really
to like feel obviously look at me I take
I try to take care of myself I obviously
understand you know I'm lucky I got a
fast metabolism but I also work out very
hard ok but bro
I eat sometimes till I feel you ever eat
so much that you feel so gross where you
feel like you know what would top it off
just getting a dirty suck you know what
I'm talking about if I was if I ate so
much I was so fat that I just sat here
and got a dirty suck like after I
[ __ ] buy some [ __ ] like you know
some [ __ ] like a lawyer just a dirty
sock from a female lawyer you know
that's how [ __ ] much I eat I eat so
much that I would just sit in a curvy
position on my couch with my [ __ ]
tummy out just getting a dirty sock from
a lawyer bro that's how much I eat
naked
I'll post by the way [ __ ] post mates do
it
all over eats it and they'll [ __ ]
show up to my house I'll eat all this
[ __ ] with my naked as [ __ ] dick flopping
around and then just imagine getting a
dirty suck by the way I'm not even horny
it's just about the eating it's about
the eating it makes you feel better that
you ate so much you're like if I just
gonna dirty suck and watch [ __ ] like
the strain on TV and start season in the
middle of season 3 just so much
disrespect going on just disrespecting
everything I'll eat I'll leave you all
this [ __ ] disrespect my body I'll get a
dirty suck and disrespect my partner and
then watch this strain start with season
3 and disrespect the producers and
actors that have worked so hard
creating the moment up until season 3
but just start in the middle in the
middle of a show in the middle
of [ __ ] season 3 episode 5 in the
middle of it
just [ __ ] we're all of a sudden where
they're like where they're like well I
don't know what to do now that we're
surrounded and you just start watching
imagine getting a dirty suck in your age
7 ice-cream sandwich isn't some pasta
it's good to have nights like that man I
don't mean to be so [ __ ] inspiring
but it's good to have nights like that
you've got to live a little one time I
saw the rock in an Instagram video how
he was there's like I never heard in and
out but I took my cast members to in and
out and he drove through and they were
like hey it's the rock and he got the
burgers and he handed the burgers over
for his [ __ ] cast mates and he didn't
eat the burgers I know I know he has
cheat days I've seen it but bro if you
drive through in and out you get a
[ __ ] burger be disrespectful
dirty sock man Darren ASAC Darren is
suck name Adam and mouth battle pal you
remember that [ __ ] poppy a song dirty
pal they even called it dirty pop that's
how disrespectful was there to pop once
that I wanna back and dance and dance
man sitting around mop when it did that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was kind of tight though
right Justin Timberlake I'm sick all
these people [ __ ] touching on my
shoulder I'm sick of people asking for
[ __ ] pictures prayer during a pop
we're all the same guy Briana look at us
put our faces on each other we got the
same haircut except for that weird one
Chris Kirkpatrick
why the thunk his head look like a
[ __ ] purple dirty pop JC Chasez or
whatever even though his last name
should be Chavez his last name is
Charles ass that's [ __ ] ridiculous
almost as ridiculous as the blonde
tarantula on his head dirty pop Lance
Bass of course is gay it was never in
question
his eyes are too blue
eggs do good at dancing my mom Joey
Fatone it's so weird that he is
definitely the one that weighs the most
and his last name is fat one Joey Fatone
last name is fat one and he's the fat
one I mean what what kind of cruel joke
was that
oh dude was that the song where Justin
Timberlake said I'm tired of singing and
then and then did like people it's dude
in the history of music there has never
been alert
then when Justin Timberlake says man I'm
tired of singing and then just [ __ ]
makes farting noises god damn that's
awesome you know what the most
illis [ __ ] moment of music was in the
world was when in that [ __ ] song with
Pharrell and Justin Timberlake when he
says to nobody hold my jacket that is so
ill it's unreal that's so ill when that
happened I actually think nobody
realized it but we skipped a year hold
my jacket what who what for no reason
just felt so dope and this song was
started with a chunk sugars yung-chun
sugars are doing to him soon shoot his
young and he just goes oh my jacket how
how dope is that that's [ __ ] James
Bond in real life [ __ ] alright
alright so I'm gonna do this here we're
gonna go we're gonna ask some oh yeah
well let me look at Instagram posts hold
on I I took a few today all right not
today this week but I'm just kind of
more like dare to pop so I'm just like I
want to do I want to do Instagram posts
but on the other hand I'm designing I
mean [ __ ] I think I could do that all
day long how annoying is that you're
gonna do it - you're gonna try it in the
car - you're listening to me you're at
the office right now doing reports and
you're gonna be like so dumb dude should
I send you should I
oh wait a minute isn't there a song yes
we're [ __ ] Justin Timberlake is being
so dumb
is there anybody dumper than Justin
Timberlake who he just wills the flutes
out where he's just like singing they
just goes flutes
it's bloom bloom bloom bloom bloom bloom
senorita no it's not that one I think
it's that one where he's just like
flutes and then I by the way I don't
even think there are flutes
there are flutes after that he just goes
flutes the [ __ ] to be like like it's
so funny to have guys who like spend
their whole life playing flutes and like
to practice and become the best flute
players and then to be like oh I get to
work with Justin Timberlake and then
Justin Timberlake is like yeah but it's
me though that makes you play flutes yes
disrespectful
I think it's senorita
so anyway should I do the [ __ ] up
Instagram post to the one side you the
one that I sent the the group and that
one is just I didn't even understand it
it is very long yeah I'm not gonna read
the whole thing actually I'm gonna read
some of it oh okay
all right uh no she's actually really
sexy I didn't notice that
I just noticed how [ __ ] ridiculous it
was what's up with chicks wearing like
so much makeup some of them and then and
then and then like like if you hug them
your shoulder is like you could like
wring it out and just use the makeup
again I don't know about this one this
one might not be the best one okay
you're
I'll do this one all right so it is time
for the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week all right
oh I like the gleam in the music a
tactic oh good gum that's our thing oh
that's our dirty pop all right so dude
by the way on Etsy there's a [ __ ]
hand-painted wineglass of Justin
Timberlake and I love how it's $43 like
who's like I have 45s too much but like
40 it took them took me a while to do it
as the settle in the middle and do 40 43
dollars they should have made a 40 $2.99
for the Kudus alright so um alright so
here's the most [ __ ] up Instagram post
of the week I already announced it so
the post is of this tatted-up girl which
is cool I love I love tattoos she's
doing a crazy yoga pose she's grabbing
the back of her foot and doing the
splits and putting the sole of her foot
on the back of her head why good for the
core weird and it's a picture of her
doing this and someone's taking a
picture of her she's obviously in maybe
a yoga studio or something like that and
it's a cool move you know she's got a
great body
she's got cool blue or green hair or
whatever the [ __ ] and this is the
comment this is the not comment caption
stop looking to other people to validate
your existence now we got to stop right
there because you posted this on
Instagram so already nonsense already
you
own against what you said immediately
the one person you are guaranteed to
spend the rest of your life with is you
oh cool thanks Robert Frost so if you
want to be happy for the rest of your
life wait no so if you want to be happy
for rest of your life
Safari make peace with yourself now
I heard that million times learn to love
and respect yourself everybody's mom
tells you that you have to respect
yourself to get respect from others
heard that 97 million times in my life
no you're worth heard it happiness is
how you see yourself mmm okay
kind of weird one that you just made up
that isn't necessarily true happiness is
not a person or a circumstance to wait
for hey not a sentence see ya you don't
need things to be different or to wait
for anyone else to start working towards
being happier now no [ __ ] happiness is
being satisfied with who you are what
you have and where you are going hashtag
oh wait no I'm not going to - I cuss and
you can find it so that's pretty [ __ ]
stupid hey by the way all those
sentiments are great when you write it
on Instagram it's nothing it's not it's
not she's got crazy cool tattoos doll
man what is I'm working out got so big
and when people used to just [ __ ]
work out and not talk about it and just
like just be like yeah I'm going to the
gym
and you be like are cool and now it's
like I don't know
all right I'm gonna take some questions
I'm gonna check the gaming the system
I'm gonna give the system I'm gonna
check out the hashtag congratulations
pod this is from Coos from Kourtney
O'Meara Court so accurately
Eckersley do you get BRM when people
pronounce your name Chris D'Elia you
know it's just D'Elia that's what it is
it's just D'Elia the apostrophe
obviously [ __ ] people up which is just
just say D'Elia it's not people say EE
the Delilah the Ilia I mean you try yeah
Delia like [ __ ] it is not a hyphen in it
it said apostrophe just say D'Elia
people try to get like nice with it you
know like [ __ ] Italian Delilah Delilah
Delia don't delude Guinea did a Honda
guy he's a dirty pop yeah so it's
[ __ ] just Aaliyah do I get blood red
man I don't get blood red Matt it's not
really their fault they just I mean it
is a little bit's not like Smith or I
don't know some other [ __ ]
[Music]
made me laugh when
person wrote my little brother turned 17
tomorrow and is therefore no longer a
baby but still a baby you know grace le
gray Sally people said you [ __ ] ibex
[ __ ] killed me too
everybody's ibex [ __ ] they were texting
each other that [ __ ] freak conch shirts
available on the website and you could
see it if you're looking at the video
[Music]
this guy Curtis De Backer at Curtis De
Backer
cool how do you feel about nicknames my
friend call me the Belgian and they've
stopped using my real name dude that's
really dorky man do not stand for people
calling you the Belgian you know why
you're not in a [ __ ] Guy Ritchie
movie okay
nobody has to come talk to you nothing
you know we gotta go talk to the Belgian
who's that they'll find out and by the
time we leave you'll be lucky if you
have all your fingers amen you were a
suit no don't be named the Belgian you
just like [ __ ] goat are in high
school you know just be called [ __ ]
Gavin de Becker or whatever the hell
your name was can't find it anymore
yeah dude
if you wear
inside you khuda or you're just an
[ __ ] either way a hundred percent
don't be having to happen Chris fight at
Cooter's bye
yeah it's uh yeah it's it's awful
my buddy Sergio love used to do this
joke about who he was like brothers
loved to wear sunglasses in the in the
club and then he would do this [ __ ]
act out where he would have sunglasses
and then walk and he would just like
walk be walking all cool and then he
would trip into the stool it was
actually really funny now don't
[Music]
Holly cold ell at Holly is not funny
what do you think of people who go on
American Ninja Warrior
uh I mean I don't know it's cool it's a
stupid course that somebody just made up
you know I don't like it's weird that
like that became the course and now
everyone works to make that course and
it's just like somebody just designed
that course that's a weird to me but you
super fit I mean it's gotta be you got
be so hard to do that [ __ ] but I watched
a guy watch American Ninja Warrior on
the plane he was next to me and he was
watching it and he was like going like
oh like next to me and shaking the
[ __ ] it was like ridiculous I was
like this guy can't you just watch it so
yeah I don't know so that's that that's
it I think I'm gonna be done but we got
all the merch at Chris D'Elia calm and
you can you can you can check out that
square cash have you switched yet
download the free square cash app design
your cash card and get it for iOS or
Android now there's a new video episodes
up on YouTube and the they usually go up
they usually go for Thursday's if not
before
and there's also Clips too you can watch
like just certain things that talked
about I want to want to put up that
eating clip I think that would be a good
clip I think people will relate to that
fat fox Boone North Carolina I'm gonna
be there at the college there on
Wednesday or if you're watching the
video that came out of Thursday I was
already there Charlotte North Carolina
North Carolina tickets to Chris Lee dock
huh Australia Adelaide Perth Melbourne
Sydney Brisbane and that's in the end of
October and then I got Columbus Ohio and
then I have a vine California
San Jose California and then I have
Winnipeg and I am announcing also
Calgary I believe soon merchandise is
getting restocked and I've got new
designs coming soon so that'll be cool I
actually can't wait to see him they're
actually really cool we didn't do a an
elder today but we'll do it maybe next
week these pins are really cool I've
been wearing one of them we've only
given out three pins so far and maybe I
get one of my brother and producer even
though one fire man speaking of fire man
on fire you got to watch that special
man
I appreciate watching it and rate and
review and tweet me at congratulations
pod or using the hashtag congratulations
pod yeah it helps if you rate and review
this [ __ ] because like I said if you
want to be in this cult and do your
[ __ ] duty as a baby you got to spread
the word of the good of the spread the
good word of the call to me that's
wearing this otherwise what the [ __ ] is
this called man what are we doing when
we group it up for I'll be an elder
won't be a baby even spread the word
thanks you guys are great be disrespect
[Music]